[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen weil mein video das ist meine
typische begrüße ich bin euch hier mit
dem gerald asamoah mal was ganz andere
und zwar machen wir heute eine
fußballschule ich habe so lange fußball
gespielt was zu meinem 18 lebensjahr
jetzt die letzten jahre nicht mehr so
wirklich aber trotzdem freue ich mich
sehr dass wir das heute machen können
und ich bin mal gespannt ob ich noch wie
gut ich noch hin
hallo gesagt man gibt auf hast du da
bist wie möglich machen also ich habe
auch langsam muss man wirklich will ja
aber ich denke dass jetzt fällt heute
aus
also wir machen drei challenges einmal
ganz tiefe schatten schießen fußball
tennis und freistößen
das war ja meine spezialität ich habe
nichts falsches geschossen aber auch
ganz wichtig vielleicht möchte noch was
zu der stiftung erzählen es geht ja
darum es ist eine wette zwischen uns
beiden und der verlierer irgendwas
machen und wenn wir hier verlieren
sollte was ich davon ausgehe dann ist er
bei mir war ich habe am 16 2 gala in
düsseldorf von der bergearbeiten leute
bedienen und damit dem schalter es geht
um die gute sache guten zweck und
deswegen freue mich sehr heute verliert
und weiß zu verlieren solltest die
chance besteht ja habe ich drei sachen
kannst du eine aussuchen
die erste ist ganz einfach du gibst mir
zwei tickets hierfür für schalke spielt
die zweite ist du bist einfach bei mir
kameramann muss kamera halten und die
dritte ist in meiner heimatstadt gibt es
jedes jahr mehr zimmer sonstigen
kilometer lauf ich bin jetzt schon ewig
nicht mitgelaufen aber vielleicht wollte
ich mich dieses jahr wieder anmelden und
dann laufen wir den zusammen heute zehn
kilometer sollte ja locker schaffen ich
muss ja nicht ernster sein aber das
glaube ich schon 30 minuten zehn
kilometer 30 minuten ja was meinst du
schaffst du so aber ich brauche eine
stunde war es ekel stunde also in guten
zeiten 45 jahren gut sein wollte ich ja
ich würde sagen ich schaffe das jetzt
auch ein fungiert sich möglichst warten
[Gelächter]
aber alles klar wir fangen an mit
fußballtennis auch ein bisschen warm zu
werden ist einfach tennis mit fußball
der bald auf einem auftritt schoko seite
ist egal oder bin ich schon sagen du
bist ok alles klar
ja super leute erste törn fußballtennis
wünsche mir glück oder so kann es ruhig
machen heißt jetzt da ich jetzt geht's
los bis 11 also bis elf bisher sicher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seife
das war falsch gedacht also anders
gedacht als genau genau aber eigentlich
reicht bis 5
das viel zu lang er war aus der bauhaus
oder
[Musik]
das hat man seinen kopf 43
naja ich was mache ich durch eine
scheiße
[Musik]
ach du scheiße jetzt entscheidender
punkt oder bis 6 bis 6 ok ich schwitze
nach der vierten runde war ich alleine
sechs junge starb aber am ende war
erfahrung erfahrung hat ist also einzeln
für dich jetzt haben aber noch 22 haben
wir nochmals freistoss
was willst du denn als erstes glücklich
was kommt wir machen hatten schließen
also leute die zweite runde laden
schießen wenn gerald gewinnt dann hast
du gewonnen hast du durch wenn nicht
dann habe ich ein problem
jetzt muss ich irgendwie hinbekommen
muss man sagen respekt das ist gut
fussball danke ich mache das lokal für
einen fußballfan ist das kalt und ich
schwitze davos gefordert wie mal gefragt
also ich fange an
[Musik]
jetzt schon scheiße ich habe schon öfter
so was gespielt aber dass jemand direkt
die ersten beigetragen hat hatte ich
noch nicht naja ok hat schon mal alle
hat schon mal fünf betroffene hat schon
mal drei hintereinander
also eigentlich kann man schon in die
umkleidekabine
[Musik]
ja
oliver netz trifft dann bin ich
sprachlos also jeder hat nach drei
schüsse er führt aber 2 1
[Applaus]
kann man glück hat zwei haben wir noch
hier dann doch oder
jeder 5 ich habe wir haben dreimal du
hast ach so ok oh ja nein das war es
aber den machst du nochmal also
glückwunsch ganze nacht nicht geschlafen
da richtig blamieren
aber ihr so stolz ich habe mein bestes
gegeben da ich nur sagen respekt respekt
offenbar ist schon bei uns normalerweise
eine der besten köpfe zu den besten
ich liebe gerade weil newskij prospekt
aber es war allerdings schnell sollen
daher hat das wort geklappt das wieder
gesehen habe was ich kann jetzt einfach
frei stellt euch den anschlüssen
mal gucken ob ich das doch wenigstens
ein bisschen kann arbeiten ja also ich
freue mich wirklich immer gerne wenn wir
verlieren ist darüber zu reden
und ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
gebt doch nach oben so geht's dann
richtig spaß gemacht
ich schwitze man noch mehr wusste ich
jetzt immer noch
[Musik]
so leid ich bin jetzt hier in düsseldorf
heute ist nämlich die gala und ich habe
ja schon meine arbeitskollegen für heute
wir sind hier nämlich in meinem bereich
im garderobenbereich und hierfür bin ich
jetzt heute zuständig und kümmere mich
so ein bisschen um die jagd und das sind
meine ansprechpartner nächsten mache ich
okay alexa loo
[Musik]
zusammen oder
man muss sagen ich habe so etwas noch
nie in meinem leben gemacht ich habe
auch noch nie irgendwie gefallen hat
oder sonst was also ist das erste mal
dass ich so leute bedienen
gerade aber macht spaß hallo zusammen
jetzt ist hier oben weiter oder macht
oder zusammen ach so
hast du hier vorne sind soll ich dafür
müssen wenn ich was falsches zu sagen
das weiß zusammen
irgendwie durch vorbei gut kennst du
hast alles gut hallo
naja henkel so leute das war's jetzt
erstmal mit dem video freut mich dass
hier auf jeden fall bis hin geschaut hab
ich wollte noch meine sache sagen und
zwar oben in der beschreibung habe ich
euch die website von der stiftung
verlinkt also ja es geht halt am herz
für kinder da kann man spenden und so
ist wirklich eine coole sache
es sind am abend von der gala 120000
euro dafür zusammengekommen was er
wirklich eine große menge ist es hat
wirklich spaß gemacht und von da habe
ich mich auch sehr darüber gefreut dass
ich da mitmachen konnte und auch das
video hier gedreht habe ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen und ja das war es könnte
ja meinen kommentar schreiben habe ich
wieder fußball spielen anfangen sollte
oder nicht hat rein wir sehen uns